hi guys today we're gonna talk about the
thyroid okay now in the past videos I
talked about the real underlying cause
of thyroid is either too much estrogen
okay because estrogen has affinity for
the thyroid it blocks it coming from the
ovary or the environment or being
pregnant or the liver gallbladder let's
say the liver is dysfunctional or the
gallbladder is not working and you can't
convert these hormones because t4 can't
convert to t3 unless the liver and the
gallbladder is really healthy but I want
to give you the basics first cyrix
stimulating hormone is made by the
pituitary gland in your brain and it's
sent down to the thyroid to basically
tell the thyroid to make its hormones
so if thyroid stimulating hormone is
high that means that the thyroid is low
it's a hypo because it's not connecting
so it's going to start increasing the
communication to try to drive it through
the same thing with influence when
insulin is high it's because the
receptors are resisting it and it's not
working so it raises it same thing with
right here okay so when TSH is low
usually it's a hyper thyroid and it's
making too much so it'll turn this
hormone down to zero okay so so anyway
if it's high it's a hypo if it's low
it's hyper t4 t3 represents the number
of iodine molecules so that's what that
the difference is but t4 is the inactive
a thyroid hormone t3 is the active form
okay but there has to be a conversion in
here to convert these hormones you need
selenium alright also to make hormones
need iodine and zinc so these are trace
minerals that you need now there is a
chemical called glyphosate okay this is
an herbicide a weed killer
it's basically Roundup Ready which you
may have in your garage to spray on the
weeds but glyphosate not only can it
block the thyroid directly and act like
an estrogen but it also messes with your
liver it alters the ability for your
liver to detoxify it blocks phase 1
phase 2
toxification so basically it's a toxin
that blocks your detoxification system
and it suppresses enzymes so now you're
all this toxic stuff starts building up
in the body and it also triggers
autoimmunity like in Hashimoto's okay
now if you're doing ketogenic diet and
intermittent fasting your system is
going to be a lot more efficient your
fuel source is going to be more
efficient so the need for thyroid
hormones is going to be less and less
and less so you may find that your
thyroid hormones go from a high normal
to a low normal that's fine as long as
that's normal it's totally fine because
you're not demanding as many thyroid
hormones okay because the thyroid
hormones are involved in the metabolism
but glyphosate is sprayed on wheat it's
in most of the corn sold the
high-fructose corn syrup the beet sugar
it's in all the soy products it's fed to
the animals so you really need to start
to be aware of that and start doing
organic now some people say well I can't
afford organic but if you're doing in a
minute fasting you're cutting down the
frequency of meals you're saving a lot
more money I would take that extra money
and increase the quality of food that's
what I would do if I were you
cruciferous vegetables very important in
increasing the ability for the liver to
detoxify okay
that's why cruciferous vegetables are
good for the thyroid is long as you're
taking seek help or more iodine from a
natural source okay the other thing
selenium is very very important to in
the detoxification of a liver as well
and that's probably why it's used to
help the conversions so I just wanted to
create this video to bring up your
awareness and convince you to really
start getting in more organic foods so
we can avoid this thing right here
thanks for watching hey if you haven't
already subscribed press the button
below and I will keep you in the know
hey that rhymes